so this is a new recent math result
we've got this here a graph which is a
network of points and lines so you could
think of it like a network of friends a
network of computers London Underground
map these are all the classic examples
of networks points and lines connecting
together it's slightly unusual this
graph look all the points that you
normally get in a graph I put them all
in one line and then you can see all the
connections being made between those
points and when you do that you know
these connections these lines they cross
each other crisscrossing is everywhere I
wonder if we can uh uncross these uh one
custom without keeping those points in a
straight line I don't know this is a way
you could uncross them maybe if I took
some of these lines maybe if I lift them
up like that they don't cross anymore oh
that's cheating isn't it and then maybe
if I take this page here and lift this
up so they don't cross anymore and what
we created is something called a book
book what do you want me doing a
Southern accent
it's a book I do proper Northern it's a
book graph so what we've done it's
created a graph using four pages so that
the lines now are uncrossed and this is
special because this is the first one of
its kind that shows that this type of
graph needs four pages
and it can't be done with fewer Pages
I'll put my book Away uh tell you a
little bit more about book graphs so
that's the idea so you're going to put
the points on a line and we're going to
try and draw our graph but we're going
to try and connect the points uh like
their pages in a book let's start with a
simple example I'll just start with I'll
just do a square Four Points so now
let's turn that into a book and that
means I'm going to put the points along
the spine of the book and it's helpful
to number these let's do one two three
and four yeah now let's do one two three
and four all in a line well one connects
to two two connects to three three
connects to four four connects to one so
it goes back like that that would be a
one page book because I've just got this
top half here that I'm using so it's a
one-page book it does depend on the
order of your vertices here so if I do a
different order you get a different book
Let's do one three four two then what do
I need one connects to two like that two
connects to three three connects to four
four connects to one so I've created a
two page book this see if we can find
something that needs three pages
um we could do something like a complete
graph a complete graph is when you have
the points and the lines and
everything's connected to everything
else so here is a classic with five
points and I connect everything to
everything else so it looks like this
now let's say I'm going to try and
minimize these Crossings because that's
kind of what I'm trying to do with this
book as well if you imagine these aren't
like elastic or string I could pull two
of these lines out so I could do
something that looks like this and it
will only have one Crossing now if I
want to draw that as a book this is how
you would do it this pentagon is a loop
so if I just name a number that's one
two three four and five I'm going to
draw out my points one two three four
and five now I'm going to do the loop
first so one connects to two clicks to
three connects to four connects to five
five connects to one and then anything
inside the loop I'll put on page one two
connects to four two connects to five
and you can see I'm going to have that
Crossing there maybe I'll save that as
the last thing I do so I've got two
connects to four two connects to five
like that and anything like outside the
loop I'll do on page two so while I've
got one connects to three and one
connects to four and then yes there was
one line that I missed which was three
connects to five because I know that's
going to cross
and so I've got two pages here looking
lovely but yeah I'm gonna have to use
three pages I'll do it in a different
color three connects to five so that
would be my third page so this graph
here needs three pages if these didn't
cross I would have been able to do that
in two pages in fact you can make a book
of any size if you've got a complete
graph with endpoints uh the book has n
divided by two pages or it's that number
rounded up so if I wanted to make a book
with 100 Pages you just do the complete
graph with 200 points so that you can
make a book of any size you want so
there's nothing interesting about that
right so who cares like what might be
more interesting though is
um what about graphs that can be
untangled right let's just look at a
specific kind of graph that's called a
planar graph when you can untangle it
here we go so if you've got a planar
graph if you can draw a loop you can do
it in two pages I can do my Five Points
again but maybe with less lines so the
Yen crossover this time so if I've got a
planar graph which means they don't
cross and I've got a loop then I can
make it two pages same as before there's
my Loop anything inside is Page One
anything outside is page two one about
if we don't have a loop
right now there's a couple of ways you
can get around this if you don't have a
loop you could do I'm going to call it a
phantom Loop uh so it could be like this
there's no Loops here I'll call it one
two three and four uh but I can make a
phantom Loop if I want to so I can go
one connects to two two connects to
three and I'm gonna put an imaginary
three connects to four and four connects
to one then using that I can do the same
idea here's the book and I can go one
connects to two two connects to three
Phantom three connects to four a phantom
4 connects to one if I wanted to and
then what's inside that Loop two
connects the four so I will draw that on
page one I would actually get a one page
book here so you can turn things like
don't have loops into something that has
Loops so really now we're interested in
graphs that don't have Crossings
that don't have loops and you can't even
do Phantom Loops so there are graphs
like that as well I'll show you an
example of what something like that
would look like there it is so we've got
a graph here it's called the Golden
Harry graph and you can see it's got no
Crossings and it has as many edges as
you can put in it as well at least
without creating any extra new Crossings
so we can't even put any Phantom lines
in this and this if we turned that into
our book is going to be a three page
book because we can't quite use the
trick I used before so the three-page
book would look like this so there we go
we've got our points in a line we've
tried our best you know we've connected
it as a two-page book and then we will
have one extra line there that they've
put in and that will have to go on the
third page so this is an example
of a planar graph which is a graph that
has no Crossings in it that needs three
pages are there any graphs that need
four pages and that was the question
we knew that there were no planar graphs
that needed five pages
so we knew the answer was going to be 3
as a maximum or 4 as a maximum and that
was the conjecture and that was a
conjecture for 30 years until uh 2020.
so only recently uh we got our graph
that's the graph I showed you at the
beginning so let's just take another
look at it it's got
275 points it's got 819 edges you
connect it up it needs four pages and
every order as well need four pages it
can't be done better so this was for the
first time a plane R graph that needed
four pages as a book if you want to see
the original planar graph so that it's
just points without any Crossings in it
yeah you'll like this Brady yeah I'm
dying to say that you'd love this it's
uh this beautiful heart-shaped
graph wow it's got I'll give you options
it's got 275 vertices 819 edges and it
was found by uh you know a combination
of computer search obviously
mathematical methods as well and they
also used just purely mathematical
methods
um to find a whole family of graphs like
this that can only be done in four pages
and not better awesome yeah
this episode was sponsored by Jane
straight there are research driven
trading firm with officers all around
the world
here are some of their locations and
they're looking for smart curious
talented people to join them could you
be one of them check out janestreet.com
and click here where it says join Jane
straight it's not just jobs on offer
although there's plenty of them they
also run various programs internships
all sorts of stuff that might be right
up your alley I visited their offices
and it's really impressive certainly
Beyond any place I've ever worked
there's more on the website check them
out and there's a link in the video
description
thank you
my guess would have been okay what is
the largest area if you had all these
you know diagonals fitting inside a one
by one box and I would have guessed
regular hexagon
but it's not so it's this thing so this
is not a regular hexagon